thank you for joining us I'm John
langler this morning 25 year old Kalia
Manning was wheeled into a Clark County
courtroom battered by the car crash
She's accused of causing Manning faced a
judge more than a week after the deadly
Collision which killed her two nieces
two-year-old Rose and three-year-old
Taylor Wilmer were killed in that North
Las Vegas crash their mother also faces
criminal charges 23 year old Ray NASA
Washington was a passenger in the
minivan but she wasn't in court
Washington is still recovering in a
local hospital their attorney says both
women will be released when bail is
posted
we're going to ask that they be released
so they can neither one of them have any
real prior record they've lived here all
their lives they have family support and
they have to bury their loved one they
have to bury their these two children
prosecutors say they may take this case
to a grand jury right now the driver who
you see right there she faces 11 felony
charges including DOI causing death and
child neglect the two will be back in
court in two weeks